5 de octubre momento de economía quién
france24 y por ello recibo con muchísimo
gusto a daniela blandón ramírez el
especialista económica daniel a la
justicia británica emitió una nueva
decisión sobre el oro de venezuela a la
muy buenas noches pues mire hay una
disputa sobre quién debe administrar más
de mil millones de dólares en reservas
de oro almacenadas en el banco de
inglaterra el gobierno de nicolás maduro
quiere retirar el oro para venderlo y
usar los recursos en la crisis del
coronavirus sin embargo la oposición
liderada por juan guaidó dice que él no
es reconocido en londres y ahora el
banco central no sabe a quién hacerle
caso
en julio el tribunal superior de londres
dijo que el presidente reconocido por el
gobierno de boris johnson era el de
waldo pero el tribunal de apelaciones
anuló hoy esta decisión porque no tiene
claro si nicolás maduro no es reconocido
para absolutamente nada o sólo para
algunas cosas el banco central de
venezuela dice que confía en que sus
argumentos formulados durante el proceso
serán confirmados el caso será
reexaminado por el tribunal
superior y al final debe determinar cuál
de estos dos rivales tiene el poder
sobre estos millonarios recursos bonos a
costa rica- daniela y es que el gobierno
de este país no negociará con el fondo
monetariointernacional cuéntenos bueno
el pasado 17 de septiembre el gobierno
presentó a la opinión pública una
propuesta para pedir mil 750 millones de
dólares al organismo internacional pero
a muchos de los ciudadanos no les gustó
que este plan implicará la venta de
algunos activos estatales así como el
alza de ciertos impuestos y también el
congelamiento de salarios públicos por
eso salieron a las calles a protestar
durante casi una semana logrando que el
ejecutivo finalmente abandonaran su plan
escuchemos hoy hago una convocatoria a
los distintos sectores que respaldan las
vías institucionales para que abramos un
diálogo nacional para resolver la
emergencia económica que afronta el país
entendiendo el sentimiento que existe
pero además la necesidad de tomar
acciones viable
el gobierno no seguirá adelante con su
propuesta inicial vamos a méxico ahora
danielle leyes que el gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador actualizó su plan
de megaproyectos de infraestructura si
señor se trata de un plan por cerca de
14 mil millones de dólares que comprende
39 proyectos de infraestructura pero
muchos quedaron con la duda de si es el
mismo aunque bastante reducido que el
que presentaron hace un año de 147
proyectos por 40 mil millones de dólares
el nuevo plan que busca crear 185 mil
puestos de trabajo comprende la mayoría
de inversiones para comunicaciones y
transporte una tercera parte adicional
irá para energías fósiles y una pequeña
parte para agua y medioambiente una de
las principales críticas alan que ha
recibido el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador es que por ningún lado
aparece la energía renovable dentro de
este plan
y ahora que estamos en plena pandemia y
de los temores por las crisis económicas
que se podrían venir más fuertes incluso
daniela pues muchos se están ahorrando y
esto está pasando en europa que datos
nos tienes mire la tasa de ahorro en los
hogares de los 19 países de la zona euro
alcanzó un máximo histórico del 24 6% en
el segundo trimestre de este año eso
quiere decir alan que al menos una
cuarta parte de los ingresos que están
percibiendo ahora van directo a la
cuenta de ahorros antes de la pandemia
era casi el 17 por ciento pero también
significa que el gasto es mucho menor
ahora que antes del brote del virus si
antes era del 8,9 por ciento de los
ingresos ahora es un 7,9 por ciento eso
representa un mínimo histórico y se debe
a que hay menos consumo según la oficina
de estadísticas muy juiciosos los
europeos habla muy bien va unos con los
indicadores económicos del día sí señor
notables ganancias en wall street tras
conocerse la aparente buena condición de
salud del presidente de donald trump y
el petróleo recuperó las pérdidas
viernes en europa las principales bolsas
también cerraron con ganancias muy
pendientes también del nuevo paquete de
estímulos que se están negociando en
washington el optimismo también se
sintió en américa latina sobre todo el
sao paulo y en buenos aires que subieron
más del 1 y el 2% respectivamente
finalizamos con la cifra del día los 97
millones de euros que ha perdido en el
barcelona fc por el 19 como no hay
visitas al estadio ni patrocinadores ni
derechos de televisión para los ingresos
se han reducido al menos en un 20% y les
deben de seguir pagando a mes y después
el recorrido económico daniela y ustedes
por su compañía siguen france24
[Música]